[音楽]
皆さんこんにちはスツのりと申します私は
クリエイターとして活動しています主に
ファッションから影響を受けておりまして
イラストを描いたり立体を書いた立体を
作ったり主にファッションお洋服に
リメイクを施したりペイントを施したりし
ています私がこの活動を始めたのは約5年
前その1年前の個々2年生の時に私は
ファッションに目覚めまし
た世界のコレクションの動画だったり原宿
のファッションスナップを見たりこの
アイテム可愛いとかこのスタイリング超
かっこいいとかそうやってどんどん
どんどんファッションに乗り込んでいき
ました
しかし高校生ですので世界のコレクション
の洋服なんてすぐ手に入るわけありません
なので自分で可愛いと思う服を
作ろうそうやって制作し発表しましたそれ
が高校3年生の時ですそれから私はずっと
今に至るまで政策活動を続けてい
ます私がこの制作活動を続けてる間ずっと
大切にして感覚があり
ますそれは可愛いという感覚です私がなぜ
これを大事にしてるか私はこの自分が
可愛いと思う感覚
を感覚に自信を持っていますその感覚に
自信を持つということは自分に自信を持つ
ということに通じてき
ますこの活動の間もちろん辛いことも
いっぱいありましたしハッピーなことも
いっぱいありまし
たその中でこの可愛いという感覚は私に
とってずっと支になってきたものでし
たどんな時だって昔を思い出したりして
やっぱりこのアイテム可愛い伝わる人には
伝わる絶対
伝わるそう思って続けることができまし
た皆さんどうでしょう何か好きなこといい
なと思うこと絶対その覚1つはあると思い
ますでこの会場にいらっしゃるお客様多分
何か1歩踏み出したいけど踏み出せない
そういう思いがある方いらっしゃるかと
思いますその時は是非昔好きだったこと
続けていたこと是非思い出してみて
くださいその中に絶対自分だけ他人には
絶対譲れないそういう感覚が1つあると
思いますその感覚がそのその一歩への勇気
につながり自分への自信になってそれから
続けることへのあなたの支えになるはず
ですそれでは本日私えっとパフォーマーと
してお呼びいただきましたとえ私はいつも
お洋服の作品が多いのでファッション
ショーという形で作品発表しておりますな
のでこちらでちょこっとフシ書をさせて
いただきます音楽映像ともに鹿児島の若い
クリエイターの方がにご協力をいただき
ましたモデルには鹿児島大学の学生さんに
ご協力をいただいております賞の中に私が
可愛いと思うエッセンスをいっぱい
散りばめてますそれではすつり
ファッションショーどうぞゆっくりご覧
[拍手]
ください
[音楽]
ヘ
he
[音楽]
ヘ
はい
[音楽]
よ
は
[音楽]
あ
T
[音楽]
あ
[拍手]
[音楽]
JA